welcome back to New rockstars this is
Rogue here the show where we pitch the
wildest series for nerdy titles you love
you know a lot of people must be on
vacation because I'm your host Tommy
Bechtel today we're going to talk about
a feeling I just can't shake a feeling
of impending
Dr Doom that is yes and going
it's the first time you've ever read
like this is your first time reading
this is going great
[Music]
going rogue with me today is an angel on
Earth and my office roommate it's
Whitney van laningham hi Whitney hi so
today as I as I let everyone know on
Twitter because Mt is not here he is on
vacation I decided that I would dress up
as Mt so that you guys wouldn't miss him
too much so that like you could still
get like the vibe that he's here so I'm
wearing uh this shirt a former layers
Obsession shirt that I know he has this
is a flannel from Walmart I made sure of
it I checked the tag and uh this is my
frog hat so hello nice hope hope you
guys don't miss Mt too much but uh if
you do it's because you love him and
it's because he loves his nerd babies
yeah I said it she said the words she
said the words well Whitney it's
fascinating to me that you chose to
dress up as someone uh because joining
us is my pal and my favorite celebrity
impersonator over on the tick tocks
Instagram screams it's Angelica's tree
is here it's good to be back let's get
freaking Rogue let's get crazy with it
hell yeah
a man I have pleasured I'm sorry a man
I've had the pleasure of knowing for
over a decade
Brendan
thank you for that intro Tommy it is a
pleasure to be pleasured by you oh and
the pleasure's all mine folks
we'll actually be able to do our best if
there's people watching folks no
spoilers here but we are thinking that
Doom is upon us impending doom Doctor
Doom to be specific we have a Fantastic
Four movie surfing down that pipeline
silver surfing who knows and the general
need
for more bad guys in the MCU it's only
fair to assume that Old Vic Von Doom
will be joining the fun very soon Doom
soon and that leads us to our first
topic today y'all topic one discussion
colon why am I definitely right that
ever K Ross is Doctor dude
let's talk Story on
I'd love to extrapolate on this point
agent Everett Kenneth Ross is the CIA
operative and former deputy Task Force
Commander for The Joint counterterrorism
Center or as I call it well
working under General Thunderbolt
Thaddeus Ross my best friend Harrison
Ford editor's note insert picture of me
and Harrison Ross was tasked to control
and regulate any and all actions of the
Avengers in the wake of the creation of
the sokovia Accords all right so we know
he was getting in it he was working in
sokovia he was making sure all the
Avengers comply and of course this Covey
Accords have been designed to limit the
heroics following several disastrous
missions Wanda blowing up the second
story of that office building however
Ross's plans had soon come into conflict
with what Steve Rogers as they targeted
his old war buddy and I think lover
Bucky Barnes definitely definitely after
that he was after he was framed for a
sudden horrific terrorist attack which
leads into black panther of course as he
took out to Chaka and then that made his
to child t'challa the Black Panther
after Tony Stark revealed that Helmut
Zemo was the only one to blame how I
never knew his first his name was
helmutton let's take a moment yeah
helmet Zemo let's take let's take a
moment to appreciate that Baron zemo's
first name is helmet okay that sounds
like an energy drink or something yeah
I've been drinking a lot the full thing
I've been drinking a lot of coke zimos
today
so now now we know the one to blame for
those attacks was Zemo and black panther
apprehended him in Everett took Zemo
into custody and interrogated him here
is where I'm leading you down my theory
Ross is very familiar with sokovia and
other fictional Eastern European nations
lot varia anyone can I interest you in
beautiful laveria what do we really know
about this guy not much he's a CIA
operative but in the real world spies
infiltrate the CIA all the time go to
Barnes and Noble there's two bookshelves
for the Boomers to read about all the
spies the CIA has been infiltrated by
okay I call that uh Boomer kindling all
right because eventually bodies we burn
them with spiders the funeral pyre is
built on spy novels or spy nonfiction
all right
he has a strong interest in vibranium a
very strong interest in vibranium it's
almost a curiosity with it perhaps he's
looking to build a suit
a doom suit no I can see that let's talk
let's go to some Bona fides for him
after upon graduating from the Air Force
Academy and and being a member of the
Air Force he has been promoted at every
single job he's had very very quickly is
that because he has a superior intellect
and Charisma is that I mean are we to
believe that that this man is just a
gifted student everywhere he goes he
moves up the chain immediately or is
there something that allows him to to be
to have this uh Superior intelligence is
he perhaps uh mutated or gifted with
enhanced intelligence now here's a
special specific example of Ross
surviving in a situation where a normal
human would not
he managed to escape killmonger he was
taken to prisoner by killmonger there's
no way the physicality of killmonger
would not have been able to overcome
Ross and he would have killed him right
yeah right Ross is a colonizer according
to killmonger's narrative he would have
killed him instead he escaped now you
cannot tell me that little old Everett
Ross Bilbo Baggins could have just
escaped killmonger unless there was
something more to him my final point my
final this is where this is all heading
there is no technology that Everett K
Ross can't use he is never fallible when
it comes to technology he understands
wakanda technology he understands uh
Shield technology he understands
American government technology he
probably even understands Cree
technology I don't have proof of that
but I bet if you look it up he's used
some Cree weapons before I believe that
is because he has a mystical magical
connection to using technology much like
Dr Doom in the comics guys arrest my
case that is quite a case that is
damn all right thank you very smart
little cute little brain yeah I love it
that was a thinker I wrote this while I
was petting a dog last night wow cool oh
that's great yeah it came from a good
place
[Music]
so you're saying ever K Ross he is he
like a born in Brad latvarian or is he I
think every K Ross was yeah who was born
Victor Von Doom okay and spent a chunk
of his life impersonating Everett K Ross
in order to infiltrate and learn as much
about the world's Technologies as he
could before he eventually reveals him
to conquer it yeah okay that kind of
makes sense is because Victor Von Doom
do three names ever K Ross three names
why wouldn't he just choose a two Namer
huh yeah he wanted to keep the syllabic
count right yeah exactly yeah I could
see that it's just how oh man that is so
that is so much scheming and planning to
be able to go through basically uh be
Victor Von Doom
um is Tommy is in your theory is he
already leader of lot varia or is this
something that is in the works that he's
planning I believe in the MCU we will
have a a senior leader of Liberia and he
is the heir to the throne and only once
he once that leader dies the uh the the
the Von Doom leadership uh Falls he will
assume his Birthright as as the leader
king of live area and then the mass
one mask comes off another mask
on baby okay all right I could I could
see this timeline yeah I love this idea
Tommy especially if it's like the Von
Dooms in Liberia or like the romanoffs
right of Russia who were like yeah they
were in charge and they they destroyed
the country and they were run out uh and
every K Ross has just been in hiding
like like you said like getting
technological uh Power uh learning how
the world Works remember he was left
alone in like the wakandan lab when he
was flying the little ship around he was
like no I'll stay behind and I'll I'll
risk it as the other ship is trying to
blast him away oh I I'll I'll sacrifice
myself once again completely unscathed
feelings with cloth all those dealings
with Ulysses claw a lot of joking uh
don't send me your SoundCloud I don't
want to listen to your music
well I'm a I'm a ruthless killer that
somehow gonna kill you why because I'm
actually afraid of you because I know
who you really are claws in on it
killmongers in on it go through the
looking glasses these dead guys are in
on it dear Mr detective I gave you all
the clues why are all the powerful dead
bad guys dead why are all the powerful
bad guys dead and here's ever K Ross
walking around Barefoot with his hairy
ass feet with the one ring to rule them
all fit as a fiddle I'm Ready for Love
yeah I like this idea Tommy because yeah
if if he does reveal himself especially
if like lavaria right now we haven't
heard of it right maybe that's because
it's like a a mess like it's it's you
know behind it's been destroyed it's
like it's poor it's economies and
shambles it has no no no uh means of
like raising its GDP and then ever K
Ross can just swoop in and be like I'm
back the Von Dooms are back and we're
gonna help you uh and he comes and just
gets rid of the leader there now there
are many ways to fly under the radar
while you're building something truly
diabolical or truly magnificent for the
wakandans they had the shielding
technology the cloaking technology where
you literally just wakanda was basically
invisible to the rest of the world right
for the telokins they're underwater
there's whole civilization exists Under
the Sea you've got to go there now
perhaps the lot varians are using a
facade of poverty oh okay War toward
remnants Cold War remnants maybe it was
bombed out by the Russians oh laveria
it's a shell of what it once was but
deep underneath the mines tinker tinker
tinker tinker tinker we're building
something here people join us foreign
yeah with their delicious structures
yeah so those fraggles ate all of their
all of their roller coasters and mine
carts we gotta vote here guys because
they say is this rogus is this bogus or
is this August Whitney I'll go to you
first I'm gonna give this an August
because I like it I'm just like
how does he have so many jobs man I only
have one job and I'm tired all the time
like I don't know
two shoots in a day and then I have to
take a nap yeah gig economy but like
okay so he's like he gets like hired
right and like all these top-notch
places doesn't he have doesn't he have
he has to do those jobs right how does
he get all these other jobs and then
still run a secret country however I do
think that it would be so [ __ ] cool
if there was just all of these secret
little underground countries all over
the place that we just don't know about
because now we have yet like you said
like wakanda is I don't know how you
pronounce that something like that and
then uh like laveria would also be great
if it was secretly super cool I would
love that that'd be awesome so that's
why it's an August for me I don't think
that that little skinny white man has
the stamina that will hold down nine
jobs at a time and I also think think it
would be really [ __ ] cool if it
happened anyways I appreciate that
Angelica okay I'll give this one
I'll give it a rogus oh yes but here's
the thing here's the thing I know that
Dr Doom is a really good artist that's
one of my favorite little fun facts so I
would like to see Everett K Ross
paint or something first you know like I
need a little bit more test it out yeah
I need a little a little bit more but
I'm on board and that is also adding to
my thing because now how's he an artist
the king of lap area
underestimating go into it two things
one the rise of amphetamine usage
prescribed over the counter by doctors
or you can get you can get legal speed
from any doctor any doctor okay anywhere
anytime I heard there was a shortage oh
well hopefully not for every case Dr
Doom he's getting a lot very in ritalins
no you're also forgetting the three
tenets of John Cena hustle loyalty
respect okay that's true as long as he's
living in the scene of Lifestyle nothing
can stop him yeah all right Brandon
August bogus or rogus I'm gonna give
this one uh an August uh because oh I I
love it I love that I want it to be true
it's really leaning rogus for me I
really want it to be true trending up uh
but I I don't know it's tough it would
be like a great twist a really it would
be it would be super super cool and I
really do want there to be another
secret place where's Ross where's
everything Ross oh he left cut to a
Countryside a lake half dried up fish
bones everywhere a man steps out of a
cottage with with a chicory mug of
chicory coffee sips it he's got a hood
on the hood pulls off the white peach
face makeup is melting off revealing a
metallic face it's half Ross half Doom
wait he's putting back and then
yes yes coming off he no longer has he
doesn't have to wear it yeah yeah he's
putting on like a fake face every day
that he looks up he looks up at a cloudy
Sky the sun just peeking out and he goes
daddy Doom gonna do some bad and then a
song plays right yeah yeah
oh thank God yeah bad of the bone
obviously
see I was thinking some Doom metal but
oh okay oh yeah the seaweed is always
greener and somebody is that's my
favorite do metal song thank you so much
that is such a great game
all right up next Brandon has a rogue
theory about what's keeping the king out
who let the king out
but first be sure to head over to
newrockstarsmerch.com where you can get
some awesome new channel merch that just
dropped including a limited edition new
rock stars enamel pin come on skater
boys put a pin on your backpack and let
the girls know you know what's up and
girls you do it too all right these pins
are for all genders any identity I love
all the new rock stars merch it's so
good give us a code dude seriously you
guys the crop tops like actually changed
my [ __ ] life I've never been happier
I can barely feel my thong I'm wearing
each one is individually numbered which
you know makes it collectible there's a
limited number so grab one fast I
personally am looking for number
69.9 and you can check out all the
awesome merch options available at new
rockstarsmirch.com my mom watches these
oh dear God we want to thank Bluetooth
for sponsoring Rogue Theory this week it
may be spooky season but nobody wants to
be ghosted in the bedroom so have your
little ghost pop up through the sheets
with Bluetooth can help give you an
extra bit of confidence when it matters
most Lucci was a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but
chewable for your little baby boys that
can't swallow a pill you can take them
anytime day or night you can plan ahead
or be ready whenever the opportunity
arises like a zombie in your pants the
process is simple sign up at
bluechoo.com consult one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you're going to receive
that prescription within days my friend
the best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office office you
don't gotta read a 10 year old People
magazine shifting it hard no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA brother it prepared pair to Ship
Direct to your door in a discreet
package but I demand they don't when I
get my Bluetooth it says Tommy's getting
a red rocket tonight
then we got a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo Rogue at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Rogue to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast my
secret I'm chewing right now we want to
thank wondry go deeper into the canals
of new Menor the minds of Casa doom and
more with the official Lord of the Rings
rings of power podcast
Let Me Tell You Folks I'm not a smart
man I'm a simple fella grew up on a farm
not an active Farm just a plot of dirt
That Grew grass and I killed that farm
every day for 10 years so my dad said
this is not a farm this is simply a
Suburban house and a cul-de-sac I need
complementary materials to understand
science fiction fantasy medical dramas
cop procedural animated shows
situational comedies any one of them I
need a podcast well thank god host
Felicia Day and several special guests
provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking series and what it took
to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
show Hunters JD Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of that incredible series finale so
thank you Patrick K thank you JD Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you jaw-dropping
stories and Easter eggs copycat you
won't want to miss watch the rings of
power on Prime video and listen to all
eight banging episodes by the official
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast for free on Amazon music
download the app right now all right we
are back Brandon taken away with our
second topic for today okay here we go
folks uh we're all super hyped we got an
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum media
trailer finally putting some respect on
the Ant-Man and the wasp's name giving
him a big big big time movie uh but it's
all about the king folks uh and here's
here's what I wanted to give you a rogue
theory for and it's around why this baby
boy Kang featured in this film is having
trouble getting into the mcu's 616 okay
because in theory he who remains is dead
right and he who remains said hey once
I'm dead they're all gonna start coming
in right and you have this powerful King
who's in the quantum realm he's got a
whole Army he's got all these ships he's
building we saw a shot of all these like
ships ready to fly out uh soldiers or
whatever they are who knows what they
are ready to go he's so smart he's
powerful he's strong why can't he why
can't he just come right in okay and I
think there's a reason for that I think
this Kang is the dumb King
thank you
okay
that's the bad one who's the bad boy all
right now here we go all right he's
all cats are smart all kings are smart
yeah but there's a still a range of
smartness okay because even if you have
a hundred smart Kings oh [ __ ] the one in
the middle is Middle smart and everyone
is average and the you know the 48
behind him are below average Kings and
this is yes the belowest of average
Kings okay and all the kings hate them
they're like this dumb King keeps mess
around he's still smart he's still
somewhat smart and he's still powerful
but they're like we're gonna stick him
in a Quantum realm and he'll be stuck
there and he won't be able to get it
okay you're just giving King here the
Rick and Morty treatment Kang is just
this king is just simple Rick he's he's
simple he's simple King this is the
dumbest cake and all the kings were like
look we hate each other right we want to
take each other's universes but we all
have to agree we gotta do something with
this guy because he's just gonna kill
everyone right he's too dumb you can't
fix it the quantum realm and he's been
down there he's been working he's got a
whole city going he's got all these
soldiers he's built all these ships he
just cannot figure how to get out of the
quantum realm
yeah yeah it's a Quantum realm yeah I
gotta do math to get out yeah that's why
he needs Scott Lang or whoever he can
get he just he he saw the signal he's
like this is my chance he pulls them in
he's like hi guys glad you're here uh I
don't know how to get out of here it's
like one of those situations I'm glad
you're here I'm so dumb can you please
help me yeah can can you help me do
basic math I am too beautiful to think
for myself yeah yeah yeah so I can leave
this place
he's too dumb to get out of there yeah
he's just a he's a empty-headed hawker
all we love yeah and he's like he's all
muscle right he's all yeah he's all
Charisma he's he's formed this Army he's
ready to go he's like man I cannot get
the door open I'm so sorry can you guys
open the door for me thank you so much
it says Paul sir you're pushing it
pretty soon
yeah so everyone's got their strengths
and weaknesses most Kings have a lot of
strengths but his weakness is a lot of
things
together okay you can't put it together
unbelievable I literally I blacked out
for half of that explanation but I am
I'm so on board with this because I kept
thinking like why is this guy who's in
the quantum realm which is a place of
power it's like this kind of like point
where in theory he should be able to get
to other universes very easily like why
is he down there what's he waiting for
what's it what's what's the problem and
I realize he just can't get out he can't
figure it out he's stuck he's stuck he's
too dumb
but he's so hot but he's so beautiful
he's so beautiful he's a beautiful
little fool like Daisy Buchanan wanted
her daughter to be you know just a
beautiful little pool beautiful little
fool and we also how it worked out for
Daisy great yeah it worked out great
yeah that's right it's super dead I mean
she didn't get charged with murder
again it's fine I want a beautiful
little fool I love my own someday is
this another Bluetooth ad or what yes
jingles
it's blue too the little tiny chew that
makes a big difference in your pants
it's blue too take it to Europe take it
in the south of France when you're
feeling kind of soft but you wanna get
hot take a blue chew let that blood flow
to your knots it's blue too
get a banging boner yeah
that's beautiful
release on Saturday but you didn't even
like they are getting a [ __ ] bonus
they didn't know that they were gonna
work here that boner bonus I will also I
will also say the king might be down
there because he doesn't want to leave
that this also plays into my my simple
Kang theory is that like he just likes
it down there I tried to get out but
it's no fun and he keeps pulling people
in anytime he gets a chance and much
like you know Lenny from a mice and men
he's petting the rabbit too hard right
yeah so he winds up killing a lot of the
people he brings down because he's too
rough with them damn we've got a lot of
literary references in today's up guys
good job
we're smarter than Kang okay yeah that's
right it's kind of like in in Hop On Pop
when he hops on pop too much yeah like
too much on pop yeah yeah yeah it's a
little bit like Goodnight Moon where he
says good night to stuff every night
his own literary references wow yeah I
really think he is it's got It's kind of
like uh The Smurfs coloring book I got
when I was a boy I'm using it as food
instead of a coloring book all right I'm
ready to vote on it please I give it a
big fat Rogue my phone just got a
Bluetooth because it's up as high as it
can get thank you we're also gonna go
rogus Bluetooth thumb all the way up
there all the way so turgid and firm I'm
like one of those cobras that has two
thumbs okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
August half a Bluetooth
because I I just I can't help but feel
like kings got I don't know this king's
got so many layers to him I I need to
believe that he's the full package
there's something keeping him whether it
be some sort of physics like he's going
if he leaves he's gonna disappear he
needs some sort of help with that
um maybe like something happened I want
to tie in the snap into this somehow oh
okay
um I don't know I'm I I think there's a
lot more layers to this but I do like
the simple Kang Theory I do like it so
if it could just get there making Wafers
it's fine if you're right if you're
right I will I don't know I'll do like a
tweet and I'll admit booking theory is
yeah yeah someone take that tweet okay
is the winner I think that's fair yeah
folks if you want your king to have a
full package order in Bluetooth
so now by my knowledge uh Brandon I
believe that makes you the in the lead
right now as we go to our Rogue Theory I
know we don't really keep points anymore
yeah yours is like yours you're
basically rogus and I'm an ogis we're
kind of like doing this
yeah I like it ah great so here's
today's Rogue question is Halloween
weekend baby and everyone's getting in
the spirit in honor of Halloween what
would be the Rogue costume for a
character from Marvel or DC to wear to a
Halloween party like a rogue character
or a rogue like what's a crazy costume
I'll give you a suggestion man thing man
thing from werewolf by night could go as
the ivy in the Outfield of Wrigley Field
for the Chicago Cubs you could just be
he could be the Outfield wall okay
that's cool that's pretty cool I like
that Grimace Grimace could go as Thanos
as dick all right go ahead okay
perfect no costumes I
I was fired by the Batman oh okay okay
okay
so
um
Alfred
as condiment man
okay so Alfred
um but an Alfred condiment man hybrid
and he just spews alfredo sauce
[Applause]
[Music]
and this was inspired by watching the
Batman I don't know how that worked out
but my brain came up with that in a
three hours I love that one okay cool
lives in my my mind Brent free rent free
I think you should have uh uh Bobby
Bobby Drake AKA The Iceman uh he he
dresses up as Jack from The Shining uh
oh yeah right and he he just does Jack
at the very end in the snow
he just goes to parties and he's like
guess who I am and he like covers
himself on ice and he's like
I like that that's good I really like
that that's a party trick I love it it's
a good part
and everyone's like haha Bobby ice up my
drink that's why I'm over here talking
about what makes you Bobby Drake cool my
drink cool my drink bottle does it work
through Solo cups does your power work
okay just throw ice in there just throw
ice in there Bobby yeah look don't talk
to me don't talk to me okay mine is
gonna be I want to see Professor X
dressed up as 11 from stranger things
because that cosplay would [ __ ] Rule
and he has the same Powers
Yeah Yeah you know and like he could
just eat a bunch of Eggos and do this
all night and it would be perfect yeah
he's also obsessed with friendship that
is an incredible he's an incredible I I
couldn't pick one of these if I wanted
to as the best I love them all you're
all winners in my house
I love you guys okay that's it for rogue
Theory thanks to Our Guest Whitney van
laningham Angelica Trey and Angelica
Trey written twice in the script
is cool it's Brandon Barron
my three best friends of the whole world
support our Channel but check out all of
our awesome merch over new
rockstarsmerch.com you follow me at
Tommy Beck told I'll follow you right
back oh baby you rock stars on all
social platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our channel here on YouTube
see you next time goodbye
[Music]